prime rib a true holiday showstopper
prime rib is definitely one of the most
impressive pieces of meat you can make
for your family your friends it's really
something a lot of people have with the
holidays or a special occasion because
of its price tag you really want to make
sure you're getting it right we tested a
bunch of recipes and different
techniques so you don't have to here's
everything you need to know about how to
make the ultimate prime rib
all you're gonna need is a great prime
rib salt pepper and a little bit of time
and patience one big debate about buying
prime rib is whether to get bone-in or
boneless a bone-in roast is known to
give you a more flavorful more tender
result because the bone insulates the
meat as it cooks but it can also be
really time-consuming to carve so we'd
actually recommend that you get a
boneless roast and have your butcher tie
the bones back on to the meat that way
you're still gonna get that great flavor
from the bones and it'll be insulated
and tender but you won't have to deal
with carving it another question a lot
of people have on buying prime rib prime
or choice if you're already splurging
we'd recommend going with the prime
grade roast while prime grade prime rib
is harder to find it really has the best
flavor if you're going baked you might
as well go big the last question is how
much did you buy we'd recommend about a
pound per person after the prime rib is
cooked you'll end up with about a half
pound per person now that you know what
kind of prime rib to buy
let's get cooking so the night before
you make your prime rib you want to take
it out of the fridge and blot it
completely dry with paper towels if you
have excess moisture the prime rib isn't
gonna dry out as much which isn't gonna
result in that crispy crackly crust that
we really want to get so once the prime
rib is completely dry you're gonna
generously season it with kosher salt
and freshly ground black pepper kosher
salt is actually less salty than iodized
salt or table salt freshly ground black
pepper is gonna add just that really
great peppery flavor whereas pre ground
it's just not the same I know this looks
like a lot but to really make sure that
the roast is fully flavored from the
inside out you need to be generous with
your seasoning you're gonna put it into
a rimmed baking sheet
the rimmed baking sheet is just gonna
prevent any juices that might you know
float out it's gonna keep everything
contained transfer to the fridge and let
it sit uncovered overnight if you don't
have time to let it sit overnight at
least try to do it for two to four hours
it'll make a big difference in your
final prime rib
once the prime rib has rested overnight
you're gonna take the prime rib out of
the free
and placed on a rack in a roasting pan
it's really important to let the prime
rib come to room temperature because if
you put a cold piece of meat in a hot
oven it's gonna bring down the
temperature of the oven and therefore
result in an uneven cook some people
cover their prime rib with butter or
other herbs and seasonings while it does
add flavor it's kind of too overpowering
this is such a delicate beautiful piece
of meat that's inherently really fatty
so adding more fat to it makes it really
intense adding other seasonings or other
herbs you can do it but you really don't
need it and be conscious that adding
some of those things might burn in the
oven so that's really it now we're ready
to roast so the trick to getting that
beautiful crispy exterior is to start in
a really hot oven we're gonna start at
450 degrees for 30 minutes then reduce
the temperature to 325 and roast for 11
to 12 minutes per pound every roast is
going to be a different weight and
therefore it cook for a different amount
of time you're spending so much money on
this piece of meat you really want to do
it right
some people prefer cooking their prime
rib low-and-slow we found that by doing
this you can get a decent prime rib but
the fat doesn't render in the same way
and you don't get the same crispy
exterior with a prime rib you definitely
want to make sure that you're not
overcooking it this is one of those
times when a meat thermometer is
absolutely non-negotiable when the
temperature reaches 120 you want to take
it out once a prime rib comes out of the
oven you're gonna cover it with tin foil
and tent it for about 30 minutes the
temperatures still gonna rise about 10
degrees to get you that perfect
medium-rare roast
it's also gonna absorb the juices as its
resting I know you might want to cook it
a bit more but really trust us for prime
rib it's such an expensive beautiful
piece of meat you don't want to overcook
it so from here it's pretty easy you're
gonna transfer the prime rib to a
cutting board to start carving it you
can also save all those amazing juices
from the roasting pan to make a no-shoe
to top your prime rib with if you want
so now we're gonna begin carving first
you want to snip off the strings that
are holding the bones back so because we
have the butcher tie back the ribs it's
really easy at this point to remove it
so now just lift the bones right off the
roast
it's so much easier than having to carve
them if we had gone a bone-in roast
typically prime rib slices are pretty
thick it's such a tender piece of meat
that if you do really thin slices it's
just gonna fall apart it's also the
holidays I mean if there was ever a time
to treat yourself this would be it when
you cut into the roast the center should
be pink
the exterior should have that beautiful
crackly skin and the fat should be
rendered that's a sign of a great prime
rib ah look at that stunning prime rib
prime rib is typically served with a
no-shoe or a horseradish cream whichever
you choose you can't go wrong
prime rib is deceptively simple your
friends and family are gonna be really
impressed and think you've been in the
kitchen working hard all day on it well
in reality you're just letting it do its
thing in the oven try it out let us know
what you think happy holidays you should
honestly make the prime rib just for the
fatty pets because they're so good it's
like meat candy it's meat candy happy
holidays
[Music]
you